this one goes out to all of y'all who's
struggling to get high views on YouTube
I'm about to tell you the secret that no
one knows about to accept me as I just
figured it out
listen carefully boys and girls hey yo
it's the number one [ __ ] lever back
the seat down relax
here have a snack have a mound or six
sack I'm sorry for my grammar swag but
we're getting up to track the song is
about Iraq no I'm not talking about the
nation I'm here to tell y'all about the
great simulation if she'll refresh your
videos for more YouTube views that she
might be seduced it might come to use we
all been there we all have struggled you
try to pay for subs
they just sonata scrubs here's how to do
collabs but they just give you some
crimes you're trying to false flag and
your massive pause tags what's your
secret do you preview so must be a trick
are they part of looming not it no its
way that can be do they work really hard
do they come in it no you got it all
wrong to shake your luncheon at it
[ __ ] put some boobs in a thumbnail
[ __ ] get some money up
[ __ ] no I can't do that it's not very
nice poem on things if I don't think
about it twice
match with the moves and it
okay I'm sorry sorry the trick is simple
I learned from the best
the secret lies within an icy pond a
plane's chest you may want to consider
having implants may wanna consider
having empty okay I don't get me wrong
I'm not being sexist as long as you that
poop they don't matter what your sex is
showing you a picture of your dick ain't
nobody's gonna click on that [ __ ] come
on man arrow that's close you should
consider how the implants you should
consider having implants everybody you
should consider having implants you
should consider having implants now that
Thomas to commit are you gonna be a
[ __ ] or you gonna make people click on
that jiggle it it just think of all the
reason
just headed and that it and make us try
your nose get busy wedding Bruce in a
thumbnail [ __ ] with some boobs and
[ __ ] get some money
[ __ ] but what about my integrity
getting as long as I can put a bunch of
booby boots in about now [ __ ] with the
burbs and
[ __ ] who should I settle never
the truth should the city Heather
by day you shoulda somehow
the solution is silicon damn it but but
I'm a boy
well honestly don't you shoulda sterling
yes but the truth should be sitting
heavy
Erbs verbs thank you